hello there my name is Karen Gordon
we're at the fifth annual Beverly has
shorts Film Festival and I'm here with
Peter John Ross who is the director of
Occidental art six minute comedy piece
and now you've come out from Ohio you've
talked to us about how you're actually
parlaying this short film into a feature
can you tell us more about that yeah
this is a it's a right now it's a six
minute short that I originally shot is
to be kind of a demo for the next
feature it's the first six pages of my
next feature film but I noticed it had a
nice stopping point so I could make it
as a short and I was using that to raise
money so what I've been doing is taking
it to film festivals because if it gets
accepted to film festivals I can use
that to investors to say hey people like
this idea people are showing this you
know the kind of unbiased third party to
the film festivals showing that it's got
even worldwide appeal that's playing in
New Zealand this moment it's playing in
Dubai next month it's playing in
Australia Canada and Germany and why is
six minutes
you feel that that's a good life so I
like short films that are shorter you
know I feel like if you're making a
short film it's 20 minutes long might as
well go for a feature at that point but
again it but that's my own personal
preferences I have seen some 20 minute
movies they're great it's just that for
me I wouldn't put that much work and
money into something that isn't gonna
have the return like a feature but I
mean I think that they can be good and
they're good for other people it's like
you know I can't dictate to other people
how long their story should be but for
me I don't feel like I have too many
20-minute stories in me so six minutes
is really it was like the first six
pages of a script it was perfect and an
ending point so even if I never got to
make the feature I'd have a
self-contained beginning middle end
story to have as a short film but it
looks like I'll get to make the feature
this August regards well like I'm going
to private investors and different
people that I've known a lot of times I
mean this is my third feature that I've
made myself and so it's something where
I've never gone to a lot of my family
and friends ever for money before so
this is the first time I'm actually
approaching them away I feel like I
think I have a good enough product that
I'll be able to get their return on
their investment a little more safely
and how are you building up a name for
yourself so that investors will want to
you know believe in your credibility and
potentially for somebody well it's like
I'm a marketing I mean it really
comes down to I really feel like you
know making the movie is not even the
halfway point and finish a movie whether
it's a short or a feature you haven't
even gotten halfway there because you
have to market it screen it get feedback
sell it and then market it again I mean
these are crucial aspects to having a
career in filmmaking if you're making
movies as a hobby you don't have to do
any of that but if you're trying to
actually have a career at it these are
all essential steps that are just not
being taken and for me I like to mark it
is you press releases about everything
an article came out today that I forgot
about back in Ohio I had to call my
girlfriend to make sure you pick up a
copy before they put the new issue out
of one of the weekly papers there did a
story about this screening and I collect
those press clippings and it's not about
stroking my ego it's about going to an
investor hey somebody that I don't know
thinks I'm worthy of writing about and
thinks that my movies are worth seeing
I'm think I'm gonna say for investment
than people that don't do that for
whatever their reasons
you